question is to which degree does this
propaganda and this ideology infiltrate
your actual
thinking
um you you give examples as like
scientists in infiltrated science oh
yeah so basically you know lucenko is
the textbook example of senkoism in
biology so because Marxism is
materialist uh they didn't like the idea
that genes pass on
um you know from one generation to the
next so lysenkoism kind of was a
rejection of um Mendel and and that kind
of genetics and if you reject genes
you're really going in a bad Direction
in terms of biology the Soviet Union's
biological biological program became an
international laughingstock at one point
lucenko claimed he crossed the tomato in
a potato
um you had things where they said they
uh had nuclear which is wait we have
fish in but they said they invented
Fusion or hard or heavy water or hard
whatever it was point being
in cultures like this your
way to achieve uh status wasn't
necessarily about your accomplishments
but about your loyalty to Orthodoxy so
if you were saying things that got to a
result that was congruent with the
broader ideology as a whole that was
much better as a means of furthering
yourself in the Arts or in the
scientists in The Sciences than if you
had something that was Innovative
because if you're Innovative it's like
well how do I fit this in with the
broader ruling ideology the problem
totalitarianism one of the many problems
is everything literally everything has
to be perceived through the lens of
ideology so and that is you know there
were
um scientists who were arrested or at
least fired because of their theories
about Sunspot developments because it
was regarded as unmarxist uh there was
just there was a there was a
an epidemic and all these horses got
sick and because the vaccine didn't work
on the horses the bacteriologists were
arrested because they were guarded as
Wreckers it's like we gave you a job you
didn't do it you're undermining the
social estate so it's kind of a
backwards series of incentives
um and it's designed to maintain at all
costs the ruling ideological
superstructure but you draw a small
distinction between the ideology and the
ideological superstructure and the
propaganda aren't those kind of
intermixed together well the ideological
is like in the sciences and what's true
in genetics or what's true in astronomy
that doesn't really percolate out to the
masses right so the the problem does not
is maybe covering this scientist's grade
or these discoveries are great but it's
not necessarily the same as day-to-day
or glorifying political leaders but uh
Providence and manifestation of the idea
that truth can be conjured up yes it can
be constructed and it could be altered
quickly and then
I just I wonder so 1984 caricatures that
I wanted to a degree
it really could control the way you
think
that like how many people it affected I
can give you an example a very easy one
so again with regarding North Korea Kim
uh the great leader Kimmel sung who was
the founder of North Korea Korea had a
tumor on the back of his neck and it was
too close to either the skull the sky
spinal column so they couldn't operate
on it and throughout his life it got
bigger and bigger and I got mixed
messages in my research about whether
North Koreans knew about it because they
always photographed him from this angle
and I met a refugee
um and I asked him like did you know
that he had this tumor she goes yeah
yeah when people played him in the
movies they would you know you'd make up
there and she goes uh it was an old war
injury and I go why would a war injury
get bigger throughout your life and she
just stood there
and she was like holy but she never
questioned it but it was the kind of
thing where they put the idea in her
head and since there's no reason to
question it she just kind of went with
it her entire life until I talked to her
Audrey his name
hi Audrey hi Audrey I wonder what
percent of the population is like that
here's the thing
if there is a cost to me questioning
lucenko is a great scientist and there's
no benefit why wouldn't I just go with
what's going to keep me my family safe
but I also mean just the psychological
there might be a very local
psychological cost so not a cost you're
going to jail but it costs like
you're going to kind of ruin the
conversation by bringing it up kind of
like yeah I don't I'm just trying to
it's like Debbie Downer right yeah but
there's also the the whole metaphor of
like there's two fish in the river one
says well man the water is really great
today and the other one goes what's
water yeah like a friend of mine uh um
Adriana her mom came to the west and
they went to supermarket and the mom's
just in front of all the Fanta this this
so just crying it's like what's going on
she goes they told us we had more food
than you
and when something is you can it's you
can underthink this story this guy's
enemy of the people he was the hero he
just offended someone this is [ __ ]
it's almost impossible psychologically
to think I'm living in The Truman Show
and that everything in the media is not
just wrong but a carefully constructed
narrative and a lie like what they're
never gonna tell the truth and how you
you know like what like you and even if
that even if you do understand that how
would you even read between the lines to
deduce what the truth is yeah it must
have been a strange experience there's
stories of soldiers the the Red Army
soldiers throughout World War II as they
go to different countries even Romania
but in Europe to just to to understand
that people live much better
than they did then the soldiers did back
in the Soviet Union and that's why a lot
of times when they went back Stalin had
them killed because they saw too much or
sent to the camps
so just to linger on this idea of free
speech so there's constant
discussion about free speech in this
modern debate about social media and all
that kind of stuff what what's your take
on it grounding it
not in some kind of shallow discussion
or Free Speech we have today but more in
the context of
and the suppression of speech in um
stalinist Russia I hate the term free
speech
um because it's used in many different
contexts some I agree with entirely some
I disagree with at all uh I don't think
everyone has something to say or
something after the conversation
um and you know I have my locals
Community
um and it used to be I think the the
boilerplate language is you know come
support free speech and free discourse
and I changed that because I I don't
like that term
um because people will tell you with
some reason that oh if you block me and
or on Twitter you're avoiding my free
speech it's like okay so I don't I don't
like that term as a whole but one of the
points of the white pill and something I
see enormous parallels with today
if you have one news Outlet or three
news outlets with identical ideology
you're not going to be able to get to
any kind of Truth or any kind of useful
information it's all going to be
pre-filtered for you it's like a baby
bird and you're eating the motherboard's
vomit right but
if you have what we have increasing now
with technology if you have a world
where everyone has a camera on their
phone if you have a world where anyone
can put their ideas out there maybe
they're banned from certain Outlets but
they're not literally vanished like they
were in the USSR that is very healthy
that is something I'm enormously
supportive of because back in the day if
you only had the TV Crews with cameras
you can only see what they're capturing
and they could edit it whereas now
we saw this recently during covid right
you had these reporters with masks on
and they're talking but the cameraman
wasn't wearing a mask so you'd have the
people on the street being like look
this they don't believe it you know or
as soon as they would start filming the
guy took the mask off and they'd film
them they go you are lying you don't
believe this you're putting this on for
some purpose whether you're leaving the
thickacy of mass or not that person
clearly does not is only putting on for
show so that's or crimes
it's people you know are anti-police
they say okay the cop said this did he
draw the gun and this guy necessarily so
on and so forth it is so much better
when everyone has access to as much of
the information as possible and can make
that informed decision themselves now
there certainly is
space for informed people to be like no
no this isn't what it looks like if you
look here if you look there it's cropped
here so on and so forth but that's still
much more useful than just having that
20 second clip that someone has decided
to edit for you
so like truth has a way of because it's
everything is so interconnected truth no
matter what has what finding his way to
the populace and also there's an there's
a big asymmetry in terms of trust so if
I tell you a hundred truths and One Lie
that lie is equal I'm I'm screwed
because once you catch me like you don't
have to kill someone every day to be a
murderer right you only have to do it
once so if you catch me in a Brazen lie
you're gonna look at everything I say
after that with an enormous grain of
salt
um so that is another big asymmetry in
favor of truth if someone trusts you you
have to be honest all the time and
you're gonna make mistakes you can own
those mistakes and be like hey this is
why I made the mistake this is why I
said such and such okay but the flip
side of that which has been
disheartening to me is that people on
the conspiracy side conspiracy theory
side of things
I've noticed how easy it is to just call
something a lie yes and then that
becomes viral for some reason there's a
desire for people yeah for anyone who
points out that the emperor is not
wearing a clothes even when the emperor
is fully clothed
so I don't know what that is but that
really seems to mess with this tooth
mechanism so when uh when it becomes
viral to call people a liar whether
they're a liar or not it's like I'm feel
you feel like on unstable ground because
it to me that idea of revealing a lie
that somebody told is a really powerful
mechanism to keep people honest but when
you're like misusing a crying wolf too
much well it seems it seems to break the
system makes me nervous because there's
also like um just if someone is a liar
that doesn't mean literally everything
they say is a Lie No but what is a lie
and what isn't I I just noticed that
there's money to be made in calling out
something as a lie
it's just
um the conspiracy theories straight up
uh the the the the the first thing some
traumatic event happened give an
explanation that's not the mainstream
explanation no matter what whether it's
true or lie there's a lot of virality
and money to be made in that and that
makes me nervous because it doesn't
matter if it's true or not it becomes
anti-establishment ideas are viral
whether they TR whether they're true or
not
sure but I think establishment ideas are
powerful whether they're true or not so
I think on the whole I think you're
right I mean and the whole it's good to
test the power centers but it just makes
me
nervous in our attention economy that
the sexy thing seems to be the
anti-establishment message
and then it feels like that becomes a
drug where you uh everything
anything The Establishment says anything
is that you should say anything in the
mainstream says must be wrong because it
comes from the mainstream I I have that
line that you you're supposed to take
one red pill not the whole bottle yeah I
am certainly one of those people who is
of the idea that they are dishonest far
more open that they're honest
um that said there are people who are of
the belief let's use an extreme example
that Trump is still the shadow president
um and and you know there's going to be
these Q Anon Mass arrests I thought this
was something that like The Daily Beast
made up to make fun of Mega but I was
just on the phone with my buddy last
night and he was like no no if you go to
truth Central they're like all over
there and if you disagree with them they
call you uh controlled opposition or a
grifter or so on and so forth this is
unfortunate or where uh trust Central
Trump's social media Outlet oh truth no
truth yeah but he he [ __ ] he forgot the
name of it himself so he's like oh you
gotta explain the jokes I gotta explain
the jokes you do like uh like the the
way Twitter puts that context you gotta
you gotta do the joke and then pause and
expl like turn to the camera and explain
and have a left track but yeah so people
know what the jokes are that's that's
how that's real humor yeah Soviet and
then we just clap and everyone and then
everybody clapped
um I think for the last two years
especially vis-a-vis kovid the
overwhelming message was the experts
know what they're talking about and if
you are questioning this you're a vax
denier and you basically should be read
out of polite society and one obvious
counter example to this was social
distancing if social distancing was
efficacious why were there no attempts
ever to bring it back right when you had
different waves and if it wasn't
efficacious why was it so insistent that
we do it all do it at the very beginning
in fact in many places you'll still see
the signs on the floor where it's six
feet apart so there's an incongruity
there and I think it we are forgetting
as a people the intensity with and
understandably to some extent if you
have this worldwide deadly plague like
yeah like it's going to be go where the
leakiest the hole is so you really gotta
kind of get everyone on board but to the
the vehemence with which we're told we
know what we're doing this is the way to
solve it if you don't do it you are
causing Mass death that I think fed in
very heavily to people's enormous sense
of skepticism toward establishment
sources